ferland je remercie mes parents avoir
fait l'amour je serai que c'était une
bonne foi pour plusieurs klô pelgag
c'est le gala de l'adisq 2014 oui on
bétonne extrait je vais m'essayer
messmer de m'inspirer
non merci mesmin merci monde est bonne
soirée je souhaite le bonheur ses
remerciements à ce qu'on vous en parle
encore aujourd'hui
ben oui bien sûr mais parce que je pense
que c'était un peu le début de ce thème
en premier album c'est la première fois
que j'avais l'occasion en fait d'être
observés par la télévision par le plus
large public donc je pense que ça marque
l'imaginaire moi à ce moment-là j'ai
j'écoutais les émissions de mesmin
j'étais très impressionné par son
travail
et puis gelé souligné et puis ça ça ça a
vraiment saisi lige donc c'est
surprenant parfois ce qui ce qui est
étonnant pour d'autres ce qui l'est
moins pour vous
de ses joies
descendre au départ est ce qui est
étonnant c'est que trois ans plus tard
au gala de l'adisq 2007 vous avez 11
nominations le même nombre que daniel
bélanger
mais oui j'ai jamais été aussi proche
des dernières heures tout ce fric
[Musique]
tu espères flatteur en fait c'est une
pensée spéciale en fait je suis super
fière et heureuse pour toute mon équipe
pour ceux qui reconnut au travers ce
parce qu'elle est on dans les onze
nominations il y en a pour les
arrangements il y en eu pour la mise en
scène pour la réalisation donc ça fait
ça fait plaisir de fêter en fait de
fêter un album qu'on ne fait rien non
plus que ça se soit rendu en fait aussi
hausse près du coeur des gens pis c'est
une belle reconnaissance puis mois sans
touches de savoir que les gens les
mystérieuses personnes qui ont choisi ce
lundi tribun et reconnaissent ce travail
le
[Musique]
à part de jeu souhaité
aux albums sont très riche musicalement
avec beaucoup de castration vous lésinez
pas sur le budget ça nous a coûté cher
tous se produire des albums aussi
grandir en fait je pense qu'il ya un
truc quand même en réaction à notre
époque par rapport à ça parce que moi
aussi je me suis dit que peut-être
demain et madame industrie pudeur qui
j'ai envie de faire le meilleur album à
toutes les époques de ma vie c'est le
meilleur que je peux faire dans le
moment puis de pommes limité pour des
contraintes liées à mon époque mais
contraire contre un budget budgétaires
notamment donc acquis pour cet album je
me suis vraiment que j'ai réalisé des
rêves en fait c'est de jouer avec des
musiciens à les mixer l'album dans un
vieux studio à paris aussi de ces deux
vraiment comme peu importe ce qui se
passe à prêter mon objectif en faisant
musique c'est pas de faire des millions
de dollars cédant vivre simplement puis
de 2,2 me révéler en fait au travers ce
pour tout le monde fou là qu'on apprend
par le coeur
shout on joue
comment
en écoutant votre musique on sent des
inspirations de gentle giant entre
autres king crimson
on pense que les jeunes de 25 ans
connaissent plus on met sa voix ça vous
branche
ben oui absolument tirer comme ça c'est
gros tout le monde est toujours étonné
qu'on connaisse se détruisent des années
peu importe le fait moi je trouve que
c'est tellement inspirant de d'aller
dans le port sepideh en fait il n'ya pas
d'époque à la musique le seuil est juste
la musique qui vieillit moins d'un la
musique des libyens qui des trucs
inspirant des trucs qui meurent avec les
années qu'est-ce qui vieillit bien
qu'est-ce qui vieillit moins bien
supertramp a bien vieilli ou malvieille
frank zappa bien dit je te tombe bien et
harmonium bien vieilli mais je mets bien
dit mais comme je serais curieuse de
voir ce qu'en dit à nouveau la nouvelle
génération mais comme moi je trouve ça
mieux
j'ai beaucoup écouté
[Musique]
mais c'est un des trucs c'est des trucs
qui ont mal vieilli baets temps l'appel
peau
[Musique]
miquelon la boucle prochain gala de
l'adisq dimanche
vous pourriez remporter un prix
avez-vous préparé votre discours de
remerciement n'ont jamais être spontané
et huit typhons
comme je suis mon avis donc d'être
organisée et lisse pour plaire à la
masse là donc je pense que juste rester
moi même mon propre regard sur toi
plaisir merci merci et bonne chance
dimanche mon gérant jean françois gandon
qu'il crut même si on m'avait dit fais
attention et les échanges se dit on y va
quand même et on est parti de mon voyage
et à la presse vous rien j'ai décidé
d'accord je reste c'est un voyage aux
bahamas